hey i'm joshua bassett and i play ricky
bowen hey
i'm dara renee and i play courtney green
hi i'm larry saverstein and i play big
red
hey i'm olivia rodrigo and i play nene
hi i'm frankie rodriguez and i play
carlos
what's up i'm matt cornett and i play ej
hi i'm sophia wiley and i play gina
porter hi my name is julia lester i play
ashlyn caswell
hi i'm joe sarafini and i play said
matthew smith
and we're the cast of high school
musical the musical the holiday special
and we're here with buzzfeed to play a
game of who's who
[Music]
who's most like their on-screen
character gary
julia oh olivia
i feel like that's a hard question
because we're all so much like our
characters except for like matt
and sophia i would say like i'm like
courtney i love makeup i love speaking
out about my activism and i just
love making sure everyone's okay and in
my character description when i
auditioned for the role
at the end it says most likely to sleep
through his alarm and i think it was
like
the second week of filming season one i
was like
three and a half hours late to set
because none of my alarms really went
off so i technically slept through all
my alarms
and i came to set and i went up to tim
federly the creator and i was like
technically
you can't be mad because that wasn't my
character description and i'm just doing
some character work
who's least like their on-screen
character
so yeah oh yeah actually that's true
matt
who's just like the gushiest sweetest
bubbliest man
ever matt cornett i would say matt
and sophia matt is uh that just shows
how good of an actor he is when he uh
is really mean on set because he's
probably the sweetest person i
i i know you know he's got a heart of
gold so and same with sofia as well she
would never do any of the caddy stuff
the dancing though is 100
real that's fast that is true well i
they actually wrote that role to fit her
a little more i believe
they changed the role to like really
emphasize how how great of a dancer that
she is which i think is super dope
who's most likely to break out into
christmas carols
yeah yeah you're totally right i often
just break out into song
but it's like a blessing josephine
i would say joe and frankie they both
would just like spin them out like
really fast that's true yeah
josh oh frankie does love christmas
i feel like josh is always singing you
know what i mean i agree
always singing joe is like constantly
singing at all times oh he should put
out a christmas album
joe if you see this put out a christmas
album who's the biggest disney fanatic
matt i don't know oh larry i didn't
enjoy
anyone yeah larry larry is very
knowledgeable
at many things and disney is definitely
one of them yeah
larry knows like every disney thing
about everything me
who did you say i said larry i feel like
he has the most
like insight to disney like he he has
all of like the
secret like little known facts i said
frankie because frankie loves disneyland
so much
or it could be dara because dara knows
every disney movie like she knows all
the disney movies
last year for our rap gifts she had a
disney character for each of us like a
disney character that she thought we
were most like
who's most likely to have a christmas
tree up
before thanksgiving dara matt gary you
have a christmas tree up right
frankie because he loves christmas
decorations daryl
dara you're so right literally has a
christmas tree up interacting up
terra is very festive i decorated it in
like a halloween pattern and then i
change it for thanksgiving then i change
it for christmas then i change it for
valentine's day
who's most likely to learn a tick-tock
dance and perform it flawlessly
sophia sophia wiley sophia
she does it like on a daily basis
multiple times a day
and flawlessly every single time
i'm not even a competition she
absolutely slays i wish i could do it
like her i wish i could be like
and do like all that she's just so good
i love her so much i feel like she does
take dark dances in her sleep
thank you i appreciate it i did get a
lot of you into tick tock though like a
lot of you are killing it
but i definitely am doing dance to tocks
all the time
who has the best christmas sweater
collection larry
i definitely don't have christmas
sweaters i have one hanukkah sweater and
it's this one
i said dara because she's such a style
icon
frankie oh i feel like frankie's got
great style that's why
oh my god matt thank you do you have
christmas sweaters though frankie
i do have like a stack of christmas
sweaters i said frankie
because as we know frankie loves to shop
so i feel like if anybody would have a
sweater collection in general it would
be him
who's most likely to be caught taking a
selfie
frankie frankie
sorry when you look that beautiful
every day who can blame you there was
one time where we did
we did something he revealed that he had
taken like over a hundred selfies that
day
alone because he found a bathtub he
thought was cool and i think it was only
like
noon or one o'clock at that point he
literally
had like 100 selfies that day but he's
beautiful he loves a good selfie
i just want to double check also i want
to remember what i looked like in that
moment because i always don't look like
this
frankie you are iconic who's most likely
to forget
to get a christmas gift for someone
really important
me i'm gonna say me you are pretty on it
with gifts
and giving though i am but i'm also very
honest about forgetting things
i'm very forgetful john me yeah
[Music]
i was gonna say either josh or matt
i have the best intentions when it comes
to christmas gifts but i always
like wait to the last minute and i'm not
able to really get what i was hoping to
get but this year i'm turning that
around
yesterday i bought a bunch of christmas
gifts for people and i'm looking forward
to
to changing the tides this year did you
get us all air pods
um who's most likely to break character
during a take
george
yeah i have to agree yeah gosh gosh
uh yeah i would definitely say me who's
most likely
to nail a scene on the first take sophia
yeah sophia oh
okay
thanks joe sometimes but other times i'm
like
today she like literally works harder
than anybody i know and she's always
like on her stuff always has her lines
memorized i feel like the fact that
sofia is the youngest one
in our past and yet has a production
company
speaks for itself i said larry because i
feel like they say one take saperstein
they do call me one take zappy on set
i'm gonna just
put it out into the universe and stay
humble about it
who's the best at giving relationship
advice kate
okay yes kate literally is literally
like the mother of our cast so whenever
we have an issue we always go to cake
sophia if you have any relationship
advice sophia gives great relationship
advice despite her being the youngest
and that
for having been in like a relationship
she is so
smart i'll give relationship advice but
i don't know what i'm talking about i
don't even know what love is
who's most likely to open their
christmas gifts before christmas
olivia she would be right open the gift
and then she'd be like oh i'm so sorry i
opened it
already and then she would re-wrap it
now gosh
oh i'm like the kind of guy that i hate
waiting for things but i also
like the surprise of like no i want it
to be on christmas morning
he's like go into a room see the gifts
make sure no one's there and just be
like
he just loves presents but i also feel
like josh just would go behind your back
and open it
who's most likely to pull a prank on set
oh gosh oh oh
gosh either josh or matt 100 yeah matt
yes i think it's between like matt and
josh both of y'all
like the pranksters are set all of our
answers are correct like there are
specific instances where all of us are
correct sofia likes to hide behind
things if she's like ahead of me and
we're walking and she likes to hot like
jump out and scare
for some reason i feel like matt and
josh you guys together
like prank each other it is a very back
and forth battle between josh and i
and once it starts it does not end i
would say a lot of y'all have pretended
that there was ghosts around me
so actually we do all collectively prank
vera that is fair
who's most likely to survive on a
deserted island
oh man that is better that's a better
choice i think i think daryl you'd be
really good at it though
yeah i feel like you would already have
like everything in like your backpack
i'm like you know what actually guys you
should have planned ahead
man yeah
you have so much faith in me so we had
just like has it together
like she just wouldn't like make it work
i think people just assumed like me
being from arkansas that i was the boy
scout but i i wasn't
your boy's got energy yeah that's good
it is it's good
who's most likely to introduce you to a
band slash musician that you've never
heard of olivia me oh you know what
olivia i changed man olivia would do
that
dara okay i agree dara very much so i
think josh too because he's always
discovering new music and new
artists oh my gosh oh a vast majority of
my music is country music
and so josh introduces me to the music
that everybody else knows
but that i don't know finally who's the
best at doing impressions of their other
cast members
frankie frankie yeah he can roast
anybody with his impressions frankie
knows how to do impressions on the spot
not only
can he do impressions of our cast but he
can do our crew he can do
people that we don't even know and we
know who they are when he does
impressions of them so i would say
frankie all the way he makes me laugh so
hard
you're right i think frankie is the
answer i think that we do less
impressions than we do like poking fun
at each other
yeah each other like every like every
person has their day we're just like
it's matt's day
everyone going like i make matt sound
like he is
south just give us a little taste
frankie oh hey y'all my name is matt
cornett
and i play i can do the most generic
matte impression which is basically
just like yeehaw yeehaw i love my car
which i say to him all the time hey
y'all it's matt cornett and i'm gonna go
drive my truck
we always pretend that matt has this
like thick southern accent he really
doesn't
thank you so much buzzfeed make sure to
check out high school musical the
musical the holiday special on disney
[Music]
plus
you